she's not aware of her behavior what I'm
saying is is that because I'm in therapy
because I go to meetings because I talk
to people about issues that I have and I
even go is this like in my therapist
today it's like what I what I tell you
what happened Friday night
sure I'm like no we get back to my album
please well we will we will but I I
acted like such a [ __ ] baby so Friday
night I'm playing The Improv in Irvine
and Empire vine improv drop hard time
getting that but I so in my head I'm
like you know normally be you know the
last years I played Irvine it's always
them calling me like where are you
uh-huh are you here because you're about
to go up and I'm like no I'm in I just
left house you said it like that I left
how I left yeah and they're like what
you know I mean like I'm you're trying
to convince them you're foreign but I
I'm always late I'm you know I and then
when I show up people have to stretch
and people get nervous and worried right
and since I'm sober again I went through
all this stuff I went through and I'm in
therapy you know I you know decide
Friday I go I'm gonna leave during the
day sure to be mindful and respectful to
them be respectful to me so I don't have
to panic and I'm gonna have a nice
dinner there and then I'm gonna do my
shows so when I showed up I they go what
do you do here so early and I told
explain to them I'm being mindful me
left house so I am me mindful yeah so I
decided I'm gonna just eat at a
restaurant and I'll see you guys at
Showtime dark fine I go to this
restaurant next door called Paul martini
martinis and I go it's kind of busy and
I go hey I'm headlining next door it's
just a table for one can I just get a
table because I had to perform no
two-hour wait yeah but you know I
continue yeah I go I'm
headliner at the improv and I can I get
a table no we're too busy so I go back
to the club and I go you have any pool
we have no pole there now I'm getting a
little angry Paul martinis
uh we can't do anything about yeah so
then they go we have a [ __ ]
connection at Javier's so I go you know
what I'll go to Javier's they go we'll
call in advance I show up to Javier's
and the two Hispanic good thing you
mention their race I was wondering tell
people do I go on
hey man I'm headlining next door you
know I'm in a rut can I just get a table
of one to two hour wait I got no I'm
they called I know they called no but
I'm you know I mean there's nothing so I
go back to the club and I don't know
what switched in my mind oh no but now
I'm I I'm not doing the shows you didn't
want to do the show he leaves and he's
driving around in circles because I'll
tell you what in my thinking at the time
okay anyone this thing ii mean i know it
sounds crazy at the time but in the
moment right my thinking is right
I sold 2500 seats I know that 30% of the
audience eats at these restaurants or
we're so I bring in traffic for these
restaurants all the comics do I'm sorry
but we do right right and also I was
just at the Cleveland hilarities I
showed up when the restaurant was closed
and because Nick and the restaurant is
so respectful they opened everything up
and they served me prime rib but just
respect
well that club is like built on respect
like that that place you always feel
like you're you grew up in the Bronx and
the mob boss loves you
he grabs your elbow you come here yes so
you you you go to places you get treated
that light and then like you know your
brother likes out of her hand right
right and then I'm like you can eat our
shitty food oh I'll get diary
before the show that's great right but I
um I acted like a baby and I go you know
what I'm not doing it and then he calls
me I call her and he's just an absolute
rage I'm not doing the shows I'm not
doing the shows who do I call her I'm
like well I don't know and I'm rude this
is how I know I'm codependent because
instead of saying you're being a [ __ ]
baby get back in there and do the shows
I was like oh yeah that's [ __ ] up Paul
martinis how [ __ ] dare they do it
right that's what I love about her
that's funny that's what's great seeing
you guys as parents Bobby's like I
walked away from the playground I left
junior there alone what did he do that's
[ __ ] up
cosign and I was like wait this is a
problem so then what you do it then the
next night I showed up again super late
to make them worried to make the Irvine
improv worried yeah that I might wasn't
gonna show up but what did I have to do
it then that next time I play
they call him brother-in-law they make
you know I mean they're proper
decision-maker
I know I know [ __ ] Chong Chong Chong
I [ __ ] know that that behavior is
crazy I'm acting like a baby and it
comes from my childhood I think you were
just hangry no no it's not hangry babe
for the cosine suppose signing too hard
I used to UM when I would drive from the
Oakland to San Francisco which I did
four or five times a week when I started
a comedy because a lot of the open mics
were there yeah every time I would get
to the Tollbooth operator I would say
how you doing
and I would say 90% of the time they
would completely ignore me and take the
money I go good nice talking to you can
I Drive every time and then a certain
point I was like I pulled up and I was
like why am I saying how are you doing
to these people am I saying it to be
kind to them in what is probably a
thankless job where you want to put a
bullet in your brain or am i doing it to
elicit proper behavior am I am I here to
teach these people who lesson and in
cordial behavior am I just trying to be
a nice guy because I'm pretending
pull up nice guy and then they they
don't they give me the result I've had
every time and then I'm like well nice
talking to you too
haha oh yeah have a nice day and I Drive
off so then I just started saying how
you doing and then they don't answer and
I take my money and I Drive it's like my
job is not to teach the world the
lessons thing is that my behavior is
rooted in when you know my parents did
[ __ ] up things to me and I felt such
injustice and disrespected right right
because your dad he would beat you up
and then he would go to Paula martinis
every first you can afford it but no so
I you know I
whenever there's some I feel there's
some sort of you know disrespect I know
I'm an injustice that I act
inappropriately and it's this so that's
what I'm saying is is that I'm analyzing
my behavior it's like at that time and I
talked to my therapist today about the
time in the movie theater with when we
watch hereditary you would see that was
no no what we did was wrong what what
happened a quick breakdown yeah
okay I'll give you a quick synopsis we
did watch a hereditary and girls head
comes off you're jerking off